many people abstain from certain actions
which we will find out today during the
course of the show are Sunnah and they
are also recommended by Allah subhah wa
ta'ala so let's start with the question
relating to one of those issues I'm sure
the taking of a bath
bathing sometimes it is taken the bath
in order to cool the body down due to
climatic conditions and other times it
is taken to remove sexual
impurity is this a permitted act during
the fast alhamdulillah
[Music]
as far as bathing is concerned that is g
whether it's done for
a religious F if you're in the state of
Junu that sexual defilement or whether
it is done to clean your body to remove
the dirt or your feeling sticky or
whether bathing is done because you're
feeling thirsty or you're feeling hot
whatever reason it's done for as long as
the person does not swallow
water the fast does not get invalidated
so bathing is permissible while fasting
and there are
several to show that it's
permitted it's mentioned in s bukari ver
number three in the book of fasting
Hadith number
1926 that AA may Allah be pleased with
her she says that the prophet it he got
up from his
sleep in a sexually defiled state in the
state of
junub while he was fasting and he took a
bath and he continued his fast that
means bathing was obligatory here
because he had intercourse with the wife
so it was compulsory and he bathed
further if you read Sun Abu da volume
number two in the book of fasting Hadith
number 2359
Abu Bakr May pleased with him he says
that he heard a man saying that when the
prophet had gone to Al arj and while he
was fasting he poured water over his
head because he was thirsty or he was
feeling excessively hot so even when you
feel thirsty or you feel hot you're
allowed to pour water over your head or
have a bath in the state of fasting
furthermore it's mentioned in say
alkari Vol number three in the book of
fasting chapter number
25 Omar pleased with him he soaked His
Garment in water and he wor
it in the same chapter say bukari number
three in the book of fasting chapter
number 25 it's mentioned that an pleas
with him he says he had a tub of water
in which he used to sit while he used to
fast so all had show us that taking Gul
pouring water over your head whether it
be for religious purpose whether it's F
whether it's optional mu whether you're
feeling excessively hot whether you're
feeling dirty whether you're feeling
thirsty in the state of fasting all is
are permissible as long as you do not
swallow water while having a bath